foreign
a rare thing has occurred
uh two times
in the past six months I have been in
complete agreement with Bernie Sanders
how does it so Dave no I mean you got it
when it is when it is what it is it is
what it is that's right one time was
when his folks watched The Borrowed
future documentary and his team reached
out to us and said they wanted to use it
oh wow and uh because they're also
against the Epic student loan failure
that's out there they're probably coming
to different conclusions about the
failure than we are but we're at least
in agreement that the thing is a failure
and they reached out to us on that and
the second time was when I looked down
at this market watch
um article that just came out where it
says the federal reserve's policy of
steep interest rate hikes is not helping
the struggling economy and is instead
hurting working Americans Senator Bernie
Sanders said I think they're hurting the
situation I think it is wrong to be
saying that the way we're going to deal
with inflation is by lowering wages and
increasing unemployment the Vermont
independent said in an interview with
NBC news's Meet the Press this is not
what we should be doing this inflation
thing is a real issue it's a global
issue and then but at a time when
working families are struggling when the
people on top are doing phenomenally
well I don't think you go after the
working people
uh Sanders also said he would not raise
interest rates any higher completely
agree Senator Bernie Sanders yeah wow I
mean this is a rarity I find myself in
agreement sometimes with people that I
am seldom in agreement with but that's
okay if they say the truth they say the
truth that's right I can line up with it
um he goes on to say some other things
of course that I don't agree with but
that's okay I mean we're
um
there's no question that uh in my mind
that the FED is using an Antiquated
monetary policy that is absolutely going
to backlash on them they're they're
going to continue to screw up this
economy rather than help it they're
trying to squash inflation that was
created by things other than an
overheated economy the economy
overheating uh you know due to too much
Prosperity God forbid uh was not what
caused this inflation that was what
caused inflation in the 70s and this is
the monetary policy that was invoked in
the 70s that's how and up into the 80s
and that's how Jimmy Carter ran interest
rates up into the 18 fixed rate for
housing
I remember trying to sell houses in
1982. 18 fixed rates for housing that
was a mortgage rate like a credit card
it's unbelievable that's what we had and
it was this very policy this very view
of monetary policy that this is how you
correct economic inflation is you it's
kind of like chemotherapy yes you try to
kill the patient yeah a different way
before the cancer gets them that's right
I mean if you if you know people or if
you've ever had chemotherapy I mean they
basically destroy your body in an effort
to destroy the cancer cells and it works
but this will work eventually but the
devastating side effects are going to be
very very real so yeah the FED is out to
lunch they're smoking crack they are
using a hammer uh they're they're
dropping an atom bomb on a piss ant here
and it's absolutely ridiculous they're
Overkill Overkill Overkill and they're
going to cause bigger problems the the
labor problem is not due to an economic
inflation it's due to the pandemic and
you bozos quarantine issues out of
Washington you disrupted the supply
chain you disrupted the labor market
and it turned into an inflationary
economy and that's what did it yeah uh
all in an effort to flatten the curve
remember when we had to flatten the
curve now we got a new curve we got to
flatten and they're getting ready to
flatten everybody with it yeah and so
now we've got mortgage interest rates of
seven percent when I blinker go there
with three percent
and uh we God forbid house prices were
doing well God forbid the housing market
was too hot
you know and uh if you let these things
burn out they burn themselves out
without going ahead and walking up in
the middle of it and just screwing
around with it Sanders is exactly right
it's going to hurt working people in an
effort to look like you're doing
something well and Jerome Powell has
said that very thing he's come out and
said in multiple occasions you can look
it up uh he has said that this is the
only way to deal with this we've got to
relieve wage pressure so that's a fancy
phrase that means they think that wages
are too high hourly wages and salaries
are absolutely high but the reality is
instead of letting the market work
itself out and yes you have some spikes
in inflation when you see wages go up
that's just the natural way it works
folks when when a target's got to hire
somebody and pay him twenty dollars an
hour and they were paying him 14 or 16
or whatever we can clap and applaud I'm
glad for that I want everybody to make
more money but Target is in the business
of profit and so they're going to then
pass the cost on to you and your loofah
is going to cost more the other factor
that has that is that has affected wage
increase is that we saw a tremendous
amount of people in the ages of 53 to
65. uh I was studying this data this
week Dave they went home they looked at
their retirement accounts and they said
we don't have to work and when the
pandemic disrupted everything they went
home and everything kind of changed they
went and said well you know what I've
got enough and they they left the
marketplace and that has created a big
gap that we see now where companies are
trying to find people and so it's up in
the ante I'm going to pay you a signing
bonus I'm gonna pay you 15 percent more
to do the same job and that's the
reality on the street that has helped
push inflation to a stubborn level that
we are now because supply chain is fixed
we don't see ships sitting off of Long
Beach anymore and and so Bernie's
writing saying that so Jerome Powell
saying we've got to drive unemployment
up he's saying those exact things we
want to see unemployment six six and a
half percent now how much the other
thing though you unemployment does not
count able-bodied people who are not
looking for work that is correct
and we've got seven million men males
seven million males between the ages of
25 and 54 that are able-bodied and are
not looking for work that's correct what
are they doing
when they're interviewed they said
screens
translation
Halo and Call of Duty yeah
uh while smoking pot in their mother's
basement
and they're 32 years old we've got a a
way too large a segment of our male
population that is completely
self-selected out of the workplace and
is creating a labor shortage yeah and
you know how are these people eating uh
let me help you with this government
support yes and some of you mamas need
to throw your babies out in the streets
so they can be Cowboys
oh unbelievable that's right that's spot
on
hey let me just tell you
an eagle that doesn't leave the nest
eventually he's known as a turkey that's
how this works so
um this is what's going on in the
economy boys and girls it's real stuff
out there we have a work ethic crisis in
America
for sure without a doubt we got people
aiming at mediocrity instead of trying
to be somebody
this is the Ramsey Show